america is now facing a dire problem
from within the seat of political power
in the u.s the washington swamp is
completely totally hostile to all
republicans all conservatives and
especially anybody that dares support
donald trump as we speak our nation's
capital is now the most liberal part of
the country than anywhere else in
america and that would include places
like california and new york and new
york city in 2020 biden carried the
district of columbia by over 92
percentage points look at that
over 92 percent that never happens all
neighboring counties meanwhile voted for
biden by at least 80 percent in other
words almost every single career
bureaucrat public servant supposedly in
the swamp in dc is a democrat or a trump
hater and of course that includes almost
every official at the doj and the upper
echelon not rank and file the upper
echelon of the fbi so
naturally the unprecedented rate on
mar-a-lago was conducted not by the
nearby miami fbi field office no no but
by an fbi counterintelligence division
from washington d.c now get this it is
the very same division of the fbi that
spent all those years perpetrating the
russia hoax in a bogus political
investigation that they proudly named
crossfire hurricane great job director
ray for cleaning this up now prior to
obtaining a warrant to raid mar-a-lago
the doj went judge shopping of course
they picked this guy a low-level
magistrate not approved by the senate
his name is bruce rinehart he made
political donations to barack obama he
expressed hatred for donald trump on
social media and even once recused
himself from a suit involving trump and
hillary because he hates trump now today
this very same judge was tasked with
deciding whether or not that the
affidavit in other words the doj's
justification for raiding mar-a-lago in
this case will be released to the public
now the affidavit could reveal the basis
for the investigation and the search
warrant and donald trump he said he's
open book he wants it released so
naturally judge reinhardt he's kicking
the decision back to the washington
swamp and he's giving it to biden's doj
so they can make the redactions oh that
means probably everything will be
redacted so we are clear the same
anti-trump washington-based fbi agents
the same exact department that conducted
the russia collusion witch hunt just
raided the president's personal home
with a warrant from a judge who also
hates donald trump obtained by the
democrats in the doj who also hate
donald trump who have been anonymously
leaking salacious rumors about the
investigation to the anti-trump
democrats and the media who are also
based you got it in washington d.c this
is beyond horrendous it is corrupt it is
an abuse of power but wait attorney
general merrick garland he promised that
the doj is not political and that he
will speak through his court filings all
court filings and a flurry of anti-trump
leaks and there are rumblings by the way
tonight that the doj absolutely
positively kept the biden white house in
the loop the entire time
let's put it this way we're watching
this very closely merrick garland is a
disgrace frankly so is the fbi director
chris wray he should have cleaned up the
mess he inherited he did not and
unfortunately it's gotten worse under
his reign this year republican senator
chuck grassley he's issued now three
letters to director ray detailing what
are serious allegations of political
bias from whistleblowers brave
whistleblowers not hearsay
whistleblowers from inside the fbi now
according to the whistleblowers inside
the fbi the fbi approved investigations
into donald trump based on questionable
evidence while attempting time after
time after time to squash an
investigation into hunter biden despite
a trove of verified material on the
laptop from hell which by the way we
need to remember implicates uh the big
guy joe and his knowledge of things that
he said he had no knowledge of now
grassley is now seeking a comprehensive
organizational breakdown of the
washington field office for further
investigation but guess what the fbi
doesn't care they're refusing to address
any of senator grassley's concerns and
now according to a brand new rasmussen
poll a majority and this is sad to me i
mean i had two fbi agents when i was
growing up in my family they were they
were deity they were revered in my
family
but you know 53 percent of americans
believe that the upper echelon of the
fbi is acting as joe biden's personal
gestapo now not words i would use but
that's what they're saying tonight there
is little doubt that the fbi and the doj
have been politicized and now they're
being weaponized beyond belief not rank
and file again the upper echelon now
people just like comey and strzok who
said they would stop donald trump from
ever becoming president in 2016 and of
course they had a plan and then they had
an insurance policy if their plan failed
so make no mistake the deep state is
real if you are a trump supporter if you
are a conservative know that they do
hate you retired general michael hayden
who served as america's cia director
after 9 11 actually tweeted that
republicans are more dangerous and
contemptible than any violent extremist
organization on earth democratic
strategists our good friend james
carville echo the same sentiment if you
rewound the tape from let's say
1992 or 1991 he'd be saying the same
thing he's like a broken record over and
over again listen
huge majorities of the republican party
don't believe in evolution
right huge majorities of the republican
party followed donald trump and
whatever that could sound to you the
problem the republican party has is they
got really stupid people that vote in
their primaries
and what when you have that
you're gonna get in really stupid people
demand to have really stupid leaders and
that's where the republican party is now
now carvel went on to call republicans
racist and evil of course we're used to
this kind of rhetoric from democrats in
the media every election cycle in theory
humpty dumpty he was hired at fake news
cnn to hold the media accountable when
in reality we told you he was nothing
but jeff zucker cnn's head at the time
stenographer who at the request of
zucker made it his life's work to stalk
and harass people like me and anyone
else that worked at fox news now with
zucker gone poor humpty dumpty has been
officially dumped all the liberal hacks
of fake news cnn will never put humpty
on the air again they can't put him back
together again
always lacking self-awareness humpty
once accused yours truly of eroding
democracy and using quote nasty little
words to spread poisonous propaganda now
at the same time he was breathlessly
pushing lies conspiracy theories and
hoaxes like the russian hoax
and dismissed the hunter biden laptop
story as a manufactured scandal now
despite all of this i may surprise some
of you humpty i don't like seeing anyone
get fired i wish you the very best in
your future endeavors probably at media
matters and like all the other on-air
hosts at cnn i do have some advice stop
being dishonest you know stop the
journalist charade you're not a
journalist just admit you're what i am
you're a member of the of the press
you're a talk show host admit to your
truth and your reality in woke terms so
you understand it you're not a
journalist you're a talk show host now
by the way humpty needs to own his truth
that he is a liberal who's obsessed with
fox and hates fox but we still wish him
the best we know he'll be watching us
obsessively hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else